[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه الكرام المتصفح سوريا الاسد
جمهوريه الحشيش ودوله المخدرات كما ابات
يسميها الاعلام الدولي
اسكوبار الشام بعد ان صار ينافس تاجر
المخدرات الكولومبيه الشهير بابلو اسكوبار
الاسديه مليارات الدولارات من صناعه
الكبتاجون وكلها تذهب الى حسابات خاصه
خارج البلاد لماذا ينهار كل شيء في سوريا
ويموت الناس من الجوع والبرد بينما تزدهر
صناعه المخدرات الاسديه وتغزل العالم
بشهاده المتضررين كاوربا والخليج والدول
المجاوره
الم يصدر قانون الكبتاجون الامريكي بعد ان
اصبحت عصابه الحشيش تشكل خطرا كبيرا على
العالم الا يستهدف القانون راسا نظامي
مباشره لانه صار راعيه مصانع الكبتاجون
والكبتاجونيين راعيه ترويج المخدرات
والمرويجين راعيه تجاره الحشيش والمتاجرين
والحشاشين الم يصبح صانع الكبتاجون الاول
والمروج الاول والتاجر الاول
لكن في المقابل لماذا لا نقول ان القانون
الامريكي الجديد لمعاقبه الرئيس السوري
محاوله يائسه للنيل من النظام الصامت في
وجه الامبرياليه والصهيونيه العالميه
لماذا لا نقول ان القانون كيدي بامتياز
ولا وجود لصناعه مخدرات في سوريا بل كلها
فبركات ومجسمات في استوديوهات قناه رقت
الغزلان بجمهوريه حنكوشيه الشماليه ثم او
ثم ثم لماذا يفرض العالم حصارا وعقوبه
جائره على سوريا ويريد ان يمنعها من ايجاد
اقتصاد البديل اذا تاكد فعلا وجود الصناعه
مخدرات في الشام الا يمكن اعتباره كل هذه
الدعايه المغرضه جزءا لا يتجزا من الحمله
الظالمه على محور المقاومه والممانعه الذي
يقوده الرفيق المناضل
اسئله اطرحوا على السيد شريف شحاده عضو
مجلس الشعب السوري الاسبق وعلى الدكتور
عبد المنعم زين الدين منسق عام في الثوره
السوريه
وتجاره المخدرات فعلا موضوع حقيقي
او من الانتقام من من النظام انت تعلم في
الاول الاخيره قانون امريكي قانون امريكي
تشرف عليه وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه نفسها
وكلام كثير في الصحافه الغربيه لم يبقى
صحيفه الغربيه الا هو تحدثت من الجاردن
البريطانيه
تتحدث عن زعيم عصابه مخدرات في سوريا كيف
ترى الامر البدايه تحيه الفيصل
العالم في البدايه راح اؤكد على امر هام
جدا يجب ان لا ينسينا اهميه الموضوع اليوم
تجاره مخدرات عصابه الاسد ان النظام
المجرم هو سفاح قاتل ارهابي بالدرجه
الاولى
يعني هو نظام قتل اكثر من مليون ونصف
مليون سوري طيب يعتقد مئات الالاف هجر نصف
الشعب السوري قتل بكل انواع الاسلحه اراها
الثروات البلاد للمحتل الروسي مع ذلك يريد
ان يضيف الان جريمه جديده الى هذه الجرائم
وكانه يابا ان يترك نوع من انواع الجرائم
او الموبقات الا وياخذ فيه المرتبه الاولى
بعد ان اوصل سوريا الى المراتب الدنيا في
كل شيء بعد ان كانت عاصمه في الحضاره
والرقي والتقدم والسياسه والفكره على
مستوى العالم كلها الان اوصلها الى الحديد
في كل شيء في حريه الراي في مستوى الدخل
المعيشه يريد ان يضيف عليها الان جريمه
المخدرات تمام
هذا الامر دفع الدول مؤخرا لاصدار قانون
الكبتاجون الذي سنتحدث عنه الان ما هو
مفاعيل واهدافه ما هي تجاره المخدرات
معامل المخدرات عند النظام سنتحدث عنها
بالتفصيل لكن الان سابدا اقول بما يلي
الدول لما ما عاقبت هذا النظام المجرم على
جرائمه بحق السوريين ولما هو ارسل وبدا
يصدر الامواج ووفود قوافر من المهجرين
السوريين لدول العالم صمتوا عنه حتى بدا
يرسل لهم ماذا الشحنات المخدرات التي
اغرقت الدول لهم الان هذا النظام المجرم
اصبح ملك ما يسمى المخدرات ملك ملك
المخدرات كما تقول في الصحف يعني هذا
الملك همم بدنا نكون شو الصفه اللي بعدها
ملك ماذا ملك للمخدرات ما هذا الاسم الذي
تصف به نفس هذا الاسم القانون القانون
كبتاجون يسمي بشار بالاسم انتبه يسمى بشار
الاسد بيذكره انه مسؤول عن هذه التجاره
بالاسم نظام بشار الاسد لان النظام السوري
ولا حكومه سوريا ولا يقولوا اي شيء لذلك
يبقى هذا الامر عار عليه وعلى عائلته وعلى
المتورطين معه وعلى اداء به وعلى المؤيدين
وعلى المدافعين عنه الى يعني قيام الساعه
ما هو هذا القانون
قانون تقدم به النائب الجمهوري فرانش هيل
في 2021 في ديسمبر 22 صادق عليه مجلس
النواب الامريكي ثم اقروا المجلس الامريكي
في 2022 المنتصف كانون قبل اسبوعين وقع
عليه الرئيس ليصبح قانون ساري ها ضمن
ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع لعام 2023 هذا المق-
القانون ماذا يتضمن يتضمن مكافحه التجار
بشار الاسد بالمخدرات قانون كبتاجون بشار
الاسد
ويضع فتره سته اشهر سته اشهر له وزاره
الدفاع والخارجيه والخزانه وزاره مكافحه
المخدرات والمخابرات وغيرها حتى يقدم خطه
استراتيجيه لتعطيل وتفكيك شبكات المخدرات
التي يرعاها من بشار الاسد بالاسم
اذا هذا القانون ينص بكل وضوح على استهداف
وتعطيل اضعاف الشبكات التابعه لنظام الاسد
على تقديم المعلومات واستخدام القوانين
بما في قانون قيصر ولا استخدام العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وعلى تنظيم حمل اعلاميه وعلى
دعم الدول التي تتلقى شحنات ضخمه من نظام
الاسد مفاعيل هذا القانون كما قلنا موجهه
لبشار الاسد وحاشيته وعصابته لذلك اصبح
الان ملاحق من من قبل هيئه مكافحه
المخدرات الامريكيه يعني بعد زعيم عصابه
دولي معترف عليه في العالم ماذا يعني هذا
القانون راح اقول ثلاثه مفاعيل هامه من
مفاعيل الامر الاول يعني وهو امر هام يعني
انه 12 سنه من بدايه الثوره كانوا يقولوا
بشار الاسد خطر على السوريين خطر على
سوريا عدولي شعبه الان بعد 12 سنه يقر
العالم ان بشار الاسد عدول البشريه عدول
الدول عدول الحكومات عدوله الشعوب لما
بيقول لك الان هذا القانون ما هو الهدف
منه بعد ان اغرق اوروبا بالمخدرات بدات
شواطئ امريكا على اهبه اتصل كما يقول
فرانشيل يعني مقدم المشروع لن يطول الامر
حتى تصل المخدرات الى شواطئ امريكا لذلك
هذا الامر اذا كانت الدول صادقه يجب ان
يعاملوه كما عاملوا بابلو اسكوبار زعيم
المخدرات الكولومبي في 1993 لما حاكموا
الجنرال مانويل رئيس بنما ايضا لما التاجر
في المخدرات واعتقلوه في 1989 وحكموا لويس
ميزه في ليبيا 1980 يوم استخدموا عليه
مصطلح دوله مخدرات الان بعد 40 سنه
بيستخدموا عليه ايضا على نظام الاسد يحيي
هذا الاسم بعد 40 سنه مصطلح دوله المخدرات
ماذا يعني دوله المخدرات يعني ان رئيسها
رئيس مخدرات ان وزير الدفاع فيها وزير
الدفاع المخدرات ان وزير الزراعه فيها هو
وزير زراعه المخدرات وزير الاوقاف
والمشايخ مشايخ المخدرات عند الاعلام
عندهم هو الاعلام المخدرات لذلك في امرين
الثاني ماذا يعني هذا الامر يعني ايقاف
عجله التطبيعه مع النظام الدول الان يجب
ان تفهم انها لا تطبع مع مجرد نظام معزول
سياسيا مجرم ابدا انما تطبع الان مع عصابه
بتجونيه يعني عم بيسلموا وعبيصافحوا طبعه
مع مين مع عصابه كبدكون وهذا الامر على
البدل بعيد يؤكد استحاله تاهيل هذا النظام
المجرم ابدا لانه ساقط سياسيا اخلاقيا
اجتماعيا اقتصاديا اخر امر اخر امر يدل
عليها هذا القانون هي خطوه لتطويق مليارات
الاسد التي يجنيها من هذه التجاره 90% من
اموال هذا النظام يجنيها من تجاره
المخدرات 90% من المليارات التي تدخل
لسوريا والتي تقدر بكام الرقم كما يقول
تشارلي ستار 25 الى 30 مليار دولار سنويا
بعد ما تقدر تحدث عن خمسه مليار وعشره
مليار الان مجله هذه البريطانيه بتقول لك
تجاره المخدرات بتجيب 90% من الصعب لان
النظام الان وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
كيف ترد اتفضل اولا اريد ان اوجه للرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد تحيه لصموده واعتقد ان
هذا القرار الذي اصدرته الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وسام ان يعلق عليه وهذا القرار
والحذاء هنا يتساواني مع بعضهم البعض لسبب
واحد لاننا نعرف اسبابه واهدافه ومن
انشائه وبالتالي نعرف ان كل ما اشتد
الحصار على سوريا كل ما تاكد ان موقف
سوريا صحيح هذه النقطه النقطه الثانيه
المخدرات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
تتحدث عن المخدرات هي البلد المنشئ
والمصنع والمصدر للمخدرات في العالم وهي
لا تعترف باي دوله
بمنطقه اي دوله بمنطقها لذلك منذ حرب همم
منذ احتلال امريكا للعراق ثم مقتل الحريري
وما بعد الربيع عربي شاهدنا كيف تاتي
الموجات الهستوريه على سوريا بنات سوريا
بمقتل الحريري منها اتهام سوريا بمتاجر
بالكبتاجون منها اتهام سوريا همم
همم اعضاء البشريه همم يعني اتهامات لا
حول ولا قوه هذا هدفه تركيا سوريا
وبالتالي اعاده صوره الى منطقه همم
الاحتلال الامريكي والسيطره الامريكيه
وحضرتك تعرف دكتور فيصل انه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تجذب اكثر من اي دوله
يكفي ان نقول انه همم كولين طاوله عندما
كان في مجلس الامن يشتكي لاحتلال للعراق
اخرج علبه من جيبه واراها المندوبين وقال
ان هذه العلبه تكفي لي احراق العراق هذا
يؤكد ان هناك شيء ما يحضر سوريا خاصه بعد
ان انتهت المعارك على الارض وانتصر الجيش
السوري في كثير من المعارك واليوم نشاهد
اردوغان يريد ان يضع يده رئيس الاسد
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع على الحشيش والكبده
الرئيس انه تاجر هذا الكلام لم يعد يؤثر
انه لا حقيقه واذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يؤثر ولا حقيقه له يعني موضوع المخدرات في
سوريا عباره عن همم مجسمات في قناه رقت
الغزلان
بيتحدث مين يصنعون ويجابهم مين اخذون ومين
نقلوا امريكا تتحدث عن كيف تكون في سوريا
هلكي بتاكل مهرب من سوريا الى الاردن عن
كيف تكون مهرب من سوريا الى لبنان وحقيقه
الامر ان ليس هناك لا من شاهد ولا من
اثبات ولا من اي شيء اخر انما الكلام
المشكله
طبعا طيب المشكله انه امريكا هي التي
تتحدث وانا اعتقد ان انك تعلم انه وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه همم تتاجر بالحشيش
في افغانستان واحتلال افغانستان وكانت
تتاجر
منذ سنوات ماضيه في المكسيك وكانت لها
علاقه بارتيجا حاكم بينما ولا علاقات مع
طالبان في موضوع الحشيش لذلك لا يحق
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتكلم عن
تهريب المخدرات
وهي الدوله الراعيه لارهابي المخدرات لذ
لا قيمه لهذا الكلام ولم نخاف في سوريا
منه واعتقد انه لن يؤثر لا من قريب ولا من
بعيد همم البينه على من ادعى اذا بدك تسكر
لي صحف همم اجنبيه كثير سمعنا صوتك اجنبيه
سمعنا صعب اجنبيه حول مقتل العشرات على يد
النظام سمعنا عن تقطيع اجساد بشريه وسمعنا
يعني اللي شفناه عند امجد يوسف وهو عم
يرمي المساجين في الحفره بعد ان يطلق
النار عليهم هذا افلام كرتون
انا في موضوع همم
ليس هناك ما يدل على ان سوريا
بلبنان في الاردن في امريكا لذلك كل ما
يقال عن ان سوريا على ان الرئيس الاسد هو
الذي يتاجون كلام ليس له واقعيه
صحف ما صحف لدينا موقع شهير اسمه التراستي
تراكر يعني موقع صحفي توثيقي لا علاقه له
لا بسوريا ولا علاقه له بامريكا ولا علاقه
له يعني موقع تحقيق بالدرجه الاولى توثيق
بالدرجه الاولى
هذا اخر هذا كي يراها الجميع هذا اخر ما
انتجه هذا الموقع التروستي تراكجر اه فقط
يتحدث عن منطقه دير الزور والميادين
والبكمال بيعطيك اياهم بالمكان بالمكان
اين موجوده مصانع الكبتاجون في تلك
المناطق فيلا تقع في حي القصور بمدينه دير
الزور حسب
اتروستاتا معمل بدالي قرب بحيره عفره في
حي القصور بمدينه دير الزور مبنى يقع في
بنايه الهندسه الكهربائيه والميكانيكيه
بشارع بورسعيد في حي العمال بمدينه دير
الزور معمل بداء الصنع قرب حديقه المعلمين
في مدينه دير الزور معمل بداء الصنع في
منطقه الخانات باطراف منطقه مدينه
الميادين شرق دير الزور معمل بداء الصنع
في منطقه الحزام بمدينه البوكمال شرق دير
الزور معمل بداء الصنع في شارع الفيلات
بمدينه البوكمال شرق دير الزور كل هذا
ممثل هذا موثق من مواقع عالميه مشهوره مثل
اتروستي همم اتراكر او المؤشر
دمشق في ابو رمانه والمالكي والبرامكه في
10 بيوت في كل بيت في اتجاهات مخدرات هذا
كلام جميل جميل
لاحد مراكز البحث في في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يقول الاستخبارات المركزيه تدير
تجاره المخدرات
وترسل الاموال عبر القنوات غير الشرعيه
لتمويل الاضطرابات في دول العالم الثالث
مثال على ذلك المتمردين في كل في الكونطره
جميل جدا جميل جدا عبد المنعم زين الدين
خليني اسالك
اذا بدنا نلحق كل كلمه تقولها امريكا فانا
اقول لك شيء امريكا يقول ريجان المصالح
فوق المواقف يعني فوق المبادئ
وكيسينجر يقول السياسه بلا اخلاق جميل جدا
هذه ليست اول مره تتعرض فيه سوريا لهذه
الحمله الشيطانيه اه ابوك يقول لك
اعطيني مئه موقع
للانتاج المخدرات في سوريا انا اعطيك
وفبرك لك الفين موقعك اذا صحت تعبير و
3000 لا يوجد صناعه مخدرات لا يوجد تجاره
مخدرات في سوريا الرئيس السوري بريء من
المخدرات والانتجارات المخدرات كبراءه
الذئب من دمي يوسف كيف ترد طبعا الفقره
اللي اجلتها الان اضطريت اقدمها حتى ما
نحكي بالمواقع وبالصحف هنبدا في الشرطه في
الامن وفي الدول اللي ضبطت شحنات المخدرات
اللي ما لها علاقه بالمسرحيات مواقع
التكلم نتحدث عن اضخم شحنه في اليونان في
2019 اعلنوا عن ضبط شحنه مخدرات القادمه
من مناطق نظام الاسد 33 مليون قرصك تقول
مخبا في علب حلوه الشرطه الايطاليه في
2020 قعدوا ضبط 14 طن مخدرات فصار هو
الرقم الاعلى في العالم قادم من نظام
الاسد في 84 مليون حبه كبداتون
السعوديه 2020 ضبطوا شحنه مخدرات 16 مليون
حبه في علب المته في ضبط ايضا في 2021
مليون ونصف مليون حبه مخدر في علبه مخبا
في الرمان الكويت اعلنوا في 21 مخبا شحنه
من نظام الاسد عبر الاغنام في دبي في
الليمون في 2021 في تركيا وصلت لا بناء
اسكندرون في 2021 الشحنه في السلطات
المصريه
اثنين ونصف مليون حبه كبتاجون في ميناء
الاسكندريه
من عند مناطق النظام نحن في الشمال الجيش
الوطني السوري اعلن في 2020 عن ضبط شحن
تحويل مليون
20 شحنه من مليون ونصف مليون حبه كبده كون
قادمه من مناطق نبل وزراء بالتحالف مع حزب
الله الاردن اكبر متضرر اللي هو بوابه
النظام للخليج وهذا امر هام انا بتمنى
الشعوب الخليجيه تسمعني بالشعوب العربيه
انا بدي دق ناقوس الخطر قبل ان ادخل
الاستديو كنت بتكلم مع ناشطين في درعا
قالوا لي البارحه الفرقه الرابعه صارت
تستلم معبر نصيب البارحه وهذا يعني انه
ايران الفرقه الرابعه يعني ايران ما هو
الهدف من الهدف هذا التوقيت مزيد من الضغط
على الاردن وعلى الخليج من اجل التطبيع مع
هذا النظام وهو يصنع الفزاعه ويخفف ويخوف
بها ويقول انا او زيحكم منها صنع داعش
صناعي
من اهم اهداف وفي ثلاثه اهداف راح اتحدث
عنها لكن هلا خليك بالاردن الاولى بابا
طول الاردن لما تتحدث الان عن مدير
الاعلام العسكري اترك المواقع في ال- ال-
الاردن العقيد مصطفى الحياري يقول الجيش
الاردني يواجه الان معركه ضد المخدرات حرب
عاشواء شعواء يعني الان من 2018 مقابل
كانت الفصائل هي على حدود الاردن ما تمشت
حالي وحده من 2012 2018 للان ما عاد
يلحقوه صار يبعث لهم اياها بكل شيء يعني
راح قال لك في ديسمبر 2022 ضبطوا ثلاث
ملايين حبه كبدهون قبل اسبوعين ضبط والشحن
ست ملايين حبه كبتاجون داخل عجينه التمر
قبل اسبوعين احبطوا تهريب 700 كف حشيش
المناطق الاسد الجيش الاردني عمليات الجيش
الاردني عمليات التهريب تقوم بها قوات
منظمه تملك عتاد وسلاح وطيران مسير يعني
قوات نظاميه الفرقه الرابعه نشاطت بعد
سيطره النظام الاسد على الجنوب
الان نتحدث يعني معامل في الجنوب 11 معمل
هذا الاساسيات في 90 معمل فرعيه فقط في
الجنوب الان تحدث عن المعامل بعد ما حكينا
عن الموضوع الدقيقه بس خليها عند عمل
هذا الكلام الرجل
لم ياتي لا من امريكا ولم يتحدث عن جرائد
هو يتحدث نيابه عن اليونان نيابه عن
الاردن نيابه عن ايطاليا نيابه عن
السعوديه كل هذه البلدان هي التي اعترفت
اجهزه امنها هي التي اعترفت بهذه النيهرات
المليارات من حبوب الكبتاجون قادمه من
سوريا ولا هي مره
هذا الكلام
لكن انت تقول ان النظام الاسد هناك في
مناطق لا تقع تحت سيطره الحكومه السوريه
وهناك مناطق قطع الحكومه السوري ممكن ان
يكون هنا معمل او هناك معمل هذا امر طبيعي
في ظل فوضى تقوم الان هذا امر لا ينكره
احد انت تعلم
هذا الكلام
وصلني من احد المعامل من اللاذقيه ما بدي
اروح بعيد اسمع علي قريه البصه
والهنادي القرداحه يديرها بشار بن طلال
ولديهم كارتيل للمخدرات على عينك يا تاجر
انت جاي من سوريا
بمشروع البحر
الاسد
ولديهم سجون وعصابه خاصه بهم ويعتقلون
الناس وسيم الاسد رجل اسال اهل طرطوس
واللاذقيه بقول لك هذا كيف تكون حتى
الروائح عنا عندي اصدقاء في الساحل يقول
لك يا اخي مش قادرين من كثر الروائح على
عينك يا تاجر وهذه القرعه وهذه الكره
من يشتغل فيها كل اجهزه الامن والجيش
يعني اذا وصلنا لهذا الحد نقول ونصرح ان
فلان وفلان وفلان بالاسماء اعتقد ان
المقصود هو تشويه عائله الاسد
صحيح
انا اقول لك هناك مخدرات في سوريا كما في
فرنسا كما في المانيا كما في كل دول
العالم امر طبيعي وخاصه ان المخدرات تنشط
بالنسبه لامريكا نشاط غريب عجيب مفيد
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ويارب اذا
لماذا تفتح الان امريكا اوروبا اعاده
علاقتها مع الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
ماذا تقول للاردن الذي يقول الان انه
يواجه حرب مخدرات قادمه من سوريا ماذا
تقول للسعوديه التي تقضي يعني حولت
بالمناسبات
قالت قبل ايام ان السعوديه اصبحت اكبر
مركز همم
المناطق الحدوديه خاصه في الاوضاع
الموجوده في سوريا لا يمكن ضبطها سواء كان
في المنطقه الجنوبيه او في المنطقه
الشرقيه وفي المنطقه الشماليه امور ليست
يعني بالعمليه سهله وانت تعلم ان حجم الان
حجم يعني انتشار الجيش حجم كبير لكن موضوع
كما قالوا ذات يوم ان سوريا قتلت رفيق
الحريري وان لديهم يشاهد الملك زهير
الصديق وان لديهم كذا وكذا
وهلا كذب لا بس انا بدي اسالك شو النتيجه
انه نفس التحقيقات ستصل الى انه سوريا ليس
لديها مخدرات بالمطلقه مثل كل دول العالم
لكنها لكن الحكومه ليس لها علاقه
وبعدين انتم تتحدثوا كل مره عن موضوع
اموال الرئيس السوري اخي يرجونا البنوك
اللي حاطط فيها الاموال رئيس سوري حكيته
عن الرئيس العراقي صدام حسين مات الزلمه
وطلع ما عنده بيت حكيته عن القذافي مات
القذافي ما طلع عنده رجل القذافي مليارات
صدرت في في اوروبا
يضحكون علينا
جميعا مليارات المليارات ص
دام
يا رجل القصه هذه اللي لطشها اللي لطش
لا لا دقيقه
من السيد مالك
ابو الخير عمل الكثير من البحوث الميدانيه
على موضوع المخدرات وخاصه على الجنوب
السوري الذي يعتبر بوابه تسيطر عليها
ايران والنظام السوري باتجاه الاردن
والخليج همم مالك ابو خير ماذا ماذا لديك
عن عن عمليات التهريب وماذا لديك من اسماء
وخاصه في السويداء وغيره كيف ترد الرجل
يقول لك ما عندنا شيء كله كده كذب كيف ترد
سمعت شويه تفاصيل الحلقه حول انه لا يوجد
اي دلائل على انه النظام متورط في
المخدرات طيب خلال الاشهر الماضيه في
السنه الماضيه خلال يعني بدايه الاشهر
السنه الماضي بتذكر التاريخ هجرت
الانتفاضه في السويداء
في قري
تي الانتفاضه قامت فيها مجموعه من الفصائل
المسلحه من ابناء محافظه السويداء ضد
المقرات المخابرات العسكريه هي المقرات كل
من هو موجود فيها يحمل بطاقات امنيه
مباراه العسكريه والامن العسكريه ومن هم
من يحمل بطاقات لحزب الله عندما تم اقتحام
هذه المختار هذه المقرات
المقرات سيطره الدوله
مقررات المخابرات العسكريه تحمل بطاقات
امنيه للمخابرات العسكريه والامن العسكري
والديرات مصانع تصنيع المخدرات يعني كان
هناك دلائل بالفيديو
موجوده على الانترنت في ممكن تشوفوها هذه
ما دليل اكبر دليل يوضح تورط هذا النظام
بصناعه وترويج
المقدمه للمخدرات في د
رعا عادي عرفات الموضوع المخدرات المنتشره
في المدارس بجن وب السجن منين
معقوله في المدارس
في المدارس صارت مثل الحليب مثل الماء
والخبز موجود ومتوفره انا عم نحكي عن مثال
اولي هذا المثال موجود
اه المخابرات العسكريه تابعه للمخابرات
العسكريه تحمل بطاقات للمخابرات العسكريه
فرع الامن العسكري تم اقتحامه من قبل
الفصائل من
ابن سويده
قتل العناصر اللي كانوا موجودين فيها كلهم
يحملون بطاقات امنيه ومنهم من يحمل بطاقات
لحزب الله شو شافوا فيها شالوا فيها شافوا
فيها مستودعات للمخدرات
وما بتتوزع بداخل سوريا باتجاه الاردن هي
كمان النظام ما له علاقه فيها
طيب والجنوب الجنوب السوري الجنوب ماذا في
الجنوب
نحن اليوم انا ما عم بحكي
معلومه هي سريه اهالي سويده و درعا اليوم
بيعرفوا كيف صارت المخدرات منتشره بين
يدين ابناءهم بالمدارس اصبحت نجيب كلام
جديد اليوم شحنات المخدرات اللي عم تتم
تخزينها بمستودعات تابعه للامن العسكري
متابعي على المخابرات العسكريه بمساعده
الناس موجودين من محافظه السويده ومن
محافظه درعا من ابناء المدينه وجميع من هو
مشارك في عمليه تتويج والصناعه
المصريات كانوا سابقا في السجون بتهم
جنائيه تم العفو عنهم بالمراسيم اللي طلعت
سابقا وسبحان الله تحولوا الى اص
ابات مخدرات
نحن ما عم يجيب حكي جديد هذا الحكي قاعدين
حكى بشكل يومي بمضافات السويده وبمضافات
درعا مع نجيب نحن معلوم جديده ولا عم نعطي
نحن
عم تكون سريه الناس عم تحكيها بشكل علن
كل ما يتم انتاجه من معامل في السويده يتم
نقله او في درعا يتم نقل
وتخدوا ما نقله اذا باتجاه الاردن الشحنات
اللي عم توصل من الاردن من وين ما هي
مناطق على اساس انه مسيطر عليها النظام
كما النظام عم يد
عي ناس من ينع
قد تجار المخدرات الموجودين لتحت حمايه
مين تحت حمايه النظام اطلع عليهم كلهم
معهم بطاقات امنيه من المخابرات عسكريه طب
الله ومن المقاومه من المانعه يعني نحن ما
عم نجيب معلومه جديده يا دكتور ولك حاجه
بعد نقنع حدا او نحن نقعد نتعب حالنا
لنقنع حدا انه في مخدرات
والمخدرات
بدهن بيعرفوا اللبناني بيعرف ودول الخليج
بتعرف انه هاي المخدرات
في معامل في عمل منظم في ناصيه
منظف موجوده هاي المنصمات مركز ايضا في
جنوب السوري جميل جدا
جميل جميل في اي نقطه مهمه ثانيه قبل ما
ننتقل للسيد شريف
كيف ترد والعراق يعني انت تعلم الان ان من
يشرف على طرق المخدرات باتجاه العراق ايضا
تعرف الميليشيات التابعه لايران والنظام
والى مو هناك اتفضل الموضوع
او الاتهام سوريا حزب الله ايران وبكره
جاي الدور على روسيا يعني الان الاتهام
حزب الله ليس لديه عمل الا تصنيع المخدرات
الحزم
السوريه وان الحكومه السوريه السوريه
يحصل في سوريا الان ليس مدبر ما ادرانا
يعني ما ادرانا ان امريكا جزء من هذه
اللعبه التي تقول عنها كبتاجون انت تذكر
منذ شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر وزعت امريكا
نوعيات من القمح على المزارعين في منطقه
الجزيره هذا النوع من القمح كان كله يعني
سيء الصنع وبالتالي اخذت اقماع سوريا الى
امريكا الذي يسرق القمح السوري
السوري والقطن السوري هو ذاته الذي يصنع
المخدرات ويرعد تصنيع المخدرات
في سوريا
واسرائيل وامريكا تصنعان المخدرات وتروجان
المخدرات في سوريا سوريا
انه يكون عليه هذا ابسط شيء انه يكون تاجر
مخدرات او هو من ايام لبنان العلاقه بينه
وبينا وطينه من 1976 لما دخل لبنان يسيطر
على مزارع البقاع سيطر على الحشيش هو من
ايام حافظ الاسد السوريين من سنوات
جديد
الان انا بدي انبه على الامر خطير جدا
الكلمه تهريب لا حد يقول تهريب كلمه انه
الدوله بتشوف المخدرات هناك الشاحنات ضخمه
فيها مئات المعامل الصغيره واحصيه منها 50
معمل كبير اذا الان تحدث لك عن المعامل
الكبيره فقط كل واحد من دول المعامل طاقته
الانتاجيه شيء مرعب الاندالك المعامل اكثر
من 50 معمل رصد دراسه لمركز التحليلات
العملاتيه والابحاث كوره 50 موقع 14 منهم
والاسماعات الكبتاجون 12 ماده الكريستال
ميت 23 و تسعه الحشيش نبدا من الجنوب
معامل حزب الله والفرقه الرابعه كلهم
مشرفين عليها في خراب الشحم في اللهجات في
مناطق الشعب في خطبه عواد حتى التاجر هناك
المعروف مرعي رويشد الرمتادي اليوم مطلوب
الان للاردن درجه الاولى كل هؤلاء بالفرقه
الرابعه العميد لؤي العلي والعميد غياث
دله كلهم موجودين على تجاره المخدرات في
دمشق
ومن قبلها العميد وفيق ناصر نعم رئيس
المخابرات العسكريه
اوصل المخدرات الى الطلاب المدارس في
السودان انا رح اقول لك موقع همم اللي هو
في السودان ذكر انه مدرسه همم عباد كامل
ومدرسه التجاره عم تنباع الدم هالمخدرات
قدام الطلاب اجوا الاهالي اشتكوا قالوا
لهم هذول عم بيبعوا المخدرات ببين احتما
هربوا بياع المخدرات يمينوا احتموا
بدوريات الامن بيعرفوا لمين تابعين ان كل
واحد بيعرف مين هم واحد بيرضع منها احتموا
بدوريات الامل هذه حادثه موثقه ومعروفه
بالاسم بيعرفوها كل اهل السويد في المعامل
في دمشق انتبه يا دكتور ينتبه العالم في
امر خطيره الان النظام لا يكتفي من دناته
بتجار وصناعه المخدرات انما يصنعها حتى في
معامل الادويه اكبر مصانع الادويه الان
معمل اوبري للاوبرا للادويه لواقع تحت
سيطره الفرقه الرابعه في دمشق الثاني في
عبر العماليه 10,000 حبه كبتاجون يوميانتج
هذا المعمل في حمص معمل ميديكو تشرف عليه
ايران على الحدود لبنانيه في عندك ثلاث
مناطق الزبداني مضايا القصير كلها مناسقه
لحزب الحشيش وصولا للقلمون الغربي ثلاثه
معامل في سرغايه معمليه في كل من كؤوس
وعسال الورد والجبه معمل في كل من تلفيته
في الساحل اللي ذكرته معمل البصه هي ديروا
يشرف عليه سامر الاسد ابن عم بشار معمل
اخر في دوير الشواف السائل يشرف عليه وسيم
الاسد كلهم ارتباطات مع نوح زعيتر اللي في
لبنان وابو سن المقربين من حزب الله في
حلب معمل في الشيخ نجار معمل الكرتون في
ريف حماه في سقيلبيه معمل حسام القاطرجي
المقرب من بشار كيف ياخذون هذه المخدرات
انتبهوا الاخوه المشاهدين راح حط لكم الان
صور وانتبهوا عليها كيف يخفون هذه
المخدرات سابقوا الشيطان في عمليه اخفاء
المخدرات فيلم اوز هذه الشحنه
وقود عليها فيس ميناء اسكندرون في تركيا
يتحدث هون عن ال في الحليب في علب حليب
الاطفال
كلها بالاسم موجوده في علب حليب الاطفال
طيب الان في ال ال علب التمر داخل البطيخ
داخل الفول
مكتوب عليها كلها وين داخل يعني كل هذا
الشحنات هذه
التمر في مصر الان تتحدثون عن داخل
المدافئ هون اتحدث
بالمته هاي الصوره اللي واقفين عليها
مؤيدين نظام عاد يشتروا المته شوف
الطوابير على المته ما كفى الطوابير الغاز
حتى على المته صار يقنعه انه في مؤامره
كونيه تنتج عندهم بتحطهم فيها على
الطوابير ما بعرف اذا سوره
وصوركم على المته وهاي مليار يورو فقط
كثير
باختصار بدي اختصر لحظه لحظه بس دقيقه
كامل اليوم نتحدث بشكل سريع راح اختصر
الصحف اللي تحدثنا عنها ما هي عباره عن
قيل عن قال يعني نيوروتامز لما نصرت في
2021 انه قالت الكبده جون يدير واقارب
البشار هن هو وماهر الاسد وغيرهم استندوا
معلومات من مسؤولين فهد القانون في عشر
دول عشرات المقابلات مع خبراء دوليين
واقليين وسوريين الجارديان بتقول لك يعني
في 2021 سوريا باتت الشريان الاقتصادي
لنظام الاسد مجله سبيكاتور البريطانيه في
2022 بتقول لك 90% من العمله الصعبه الان
النظام عم بيجيبها من دوله مخدرات 800
مليون دولار هي يعني اقتصادرات السوريه
بين مصادرات الكبتاجون 10 اضعاف يعني دوله
مخدرات وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه في 2022
اله 80%
في مخدرات لكن هاي وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
في نوفمبر 2022 قالت لك انه 80% من
الكبتاجون في العالم مصدره نظام الاسد 80%
يعني وماذا شوف الاهم انه واحد من كل عشر
شحنات اللي يعني ذو القبض عليها او تقتلوا
الباقي للساوين عم بيروح الان ديرشبيجن
بتقول لك انه بتحدث الان عن التقرير اللي
وصل للمخدرات للسعوديه ورومانيا وايطاليا
ومصر لك كلها من ميناء اللاذقيه تحت اشراف
الفرقه الرابعه مين بناء اللاذقيه سيطرهن
تحت سيطرتكم وين لكان خليك شويه
الامريكيه تتحدث انه السعوديه الان
السعوديه اللي ربنا يحميها ان شاء الله
وكل البلاد الان صاروا يغرقوها بالمخدرات
لدرجه صار فيها شحنات ضخمه كلها قادمه من
مناطق الحسد
مهم جدا بس اخر اخر اختصار
قالت انه فينا ساعي اردنيه
وقف تهريب المخدرات يعني ابتزاز شو عم
بتقول لك هنا الصحيفه عم بتقول لك نقلا عن
مسؤول مصادر مخابراتيه اردنيه ان ميليشيا
الفرقه الرابعه التي يقودها ماهر شقيق
بشار هو المسؤول الابرز عن تصنيع وتهريب
الكبتاجون بالاشتراك مع المخابرات
العسكريه وحزب الله هذا كلام هن الاردن
نفسهم صحيح ما بدي يواجهوهم لانه
عرفانينهم يعني قادرين بهذا الكلام
بس بس دقيقه بس دقيقه بس بدي اسالك سؤال
بس انا بدي اسالك سؤال مهم جدا يا استاذ
شريف يا استاذ شريف
من المعلمين في الجنوب السوري
قالوا لي بالحرف الواحد هلا بالمناسبه في
السويداء هناك خيام موجوده في كل مكان في
الداخل تدخل الى الخيمه وتشتري مخدرات هل
تعلم ان المخدرات في الجنوب السوري ارخص
من المصاص ارخص من اي ماده ثانيه يبيعونها
ارخص ماده لشراء هي المخدرات هل يعقل انهم
اغرقوا المدارس السوريه والجامعات
بالمخدرات انا بدي اسالك يعني هذه الاطفال
يضعوا لهم من المخدرات في علب البسكوت طفل
لسه طفل طيب هذا النظام او هذا الرئيس هل
يعقل ان يدمر جيل باكمله من الاطفال طيب
هذا يعني انا الا يخشى الله الا يخاف الله
بس دقيقه هذا النظام الذي يدمر جيل باكمله
من الاطفال بعد ان دمر سوريا وكذا الان
يدمر الاطفال يا رجل انت انت سوري
اكمل الكلام
ذكر ضيفك انه شيء 80 او 100
صحف صحف وليس فقط
انا سالتك انه هل يعقل هل يعقل نظام او
رئيس يغرق الاطفال بالمخدرات ماذا تريد من
الاطفال يا بشار ماذا تريد يا بشار انا
اعتقد من قال شوف دكتور يحطها عندك انا
اعتقد من قال انه يجب جمع 2000 مليار
دولار لتدمير سوريا هو ذاته الذي يدفع
الان مليارات الدولارات لتدمير سوريا من
الداخل حلو حلو بندر بن سلطان باجتماع مع
انت تعلم مع هذا الاجتماع
وزير التعليم عندهم دارم الطباع ابنه مهاب
ابنه مهاب هو عم بيشارك هو الوزير التعليم
في مؤتمر حول التعليم وابنه مواد تاجر
مخدرات صارت الصفحات المؤيده عندهم حطوا
حد لابنكم قبل ما تروحوا
بس خليه يكمل تفضل يعني لا يخوفونا انه
حكيت وحكيت فلانه وحكت فلان من يدير
المعامل ومن يدير المصانع هو نفسه الذي
اراد اسقاط الحكومه السوريه وجمعه 2000
مليار دولار لاسقاط النظام هي نقطه النقطه
الثانيه في المناطق ال-
المعارضه الغير مسيطره عليها وانت شفت
قديش المشاكلهم اكثر من 10 معامل و20 منها
الى الداخل والخارج هذا الموضوع معروف في
تركيا لديهم عامر
ايه لذلك مو كل شغلين زدتها على النظام
حلو انا قلت لك انه ممكن يكون هناك معامل
انا ما بخفي هذا لكن من مسؤول عن هذه
المعامل هذا السؤال الذي يجب ان يطرح نفسه
بالتالي
عن ان الرئيس الاسد لا يخشى الله او يخشى
الله لا اعتقد ان رئيس دوله ااه يذهب يذهب
بمنطق القتل او تصفيه الحسابات مع اطفال
لذلك يجب علينا ان ننتبه من هو الذي يقف
خلف موضوع المخدرات
وهاجر الى تركيا مجموعات المسلحه يعلم كيف
يشتغلون بالحشيش ولا يخفى عليها ويسالوا
زهران علوش
بعد فتره
كبتاجون بشار
الى تركيا
هذا السؤال كثيرون
يرفضون تشبيهك
لبشار باسكوبار
انت تشبه بشار الاسد باسكوبار تاجر
المخدرات الكوبي الكرنب الشهير يقول لك
همم
اسكوبار
من امواله للفقراء للمحتاجين فانا مدن
باكملها
بينما بشار الاسد يموت شعبه من الجوع ومن
البرد وليس لديه اي شيء بينما ملياراته
مليارات المخدرات تذهب الى حساباته الخاصه
يقول لك عيب اصلا كبار مجله
[موسيقى]
ميست البريطانيه لما بتقلك دمشق كاسوء
بديني ولما بتقول لك 90% تحت خط الفقر
وبتصنف مؤشر ناتج انه سوريا الاكثر فسادا
كل اللي بيجيبها ارباح مخدرات اليوم اللي
عندهم دخل الموظف ما بيستطيع يشتري راتبه
كيلو لحمه ما بيستطيع يشتري جره غاز وين
عم تروح المليارات لحظه
انا الان عم
اتحدثهم بالمخدرات ما اخذ فقط المليارات
عم ياخذ الجيبهم اللي بدي يهرب منه الان
كان جواز السفر نصف مليون سوري سوا مليون
سوري يعني راتب سنه بده يتفاعل ياخذ جواز
سفر وهو الجواز ثاني اسوء جواز في العالم
يروح على اي دوله الان الليره السوريه
صارت 7000 لهذا النظام المجرم بالمخدرات
انتهى الوقت
انا بقول اذا اخر كلمه
نحن بالنسبه لنا سوريا نعتبرها سوريه
الشعب سوريا الحضاره سوريا الحريه سوريا
اللي راح نرفع راسنا فيها النظام المجرم
اذا هو بده يسويه الكيماوي او سوريه
اسمع اسمع الثوره السوريه
كبتاج سوريا
[موسيقى]